well i would say I'll tell you my own
feeling about this I mean right now he
could you go out go to the streets in
New York and asked that question you got
some people you know pretty fired up I i
I've never been a you know bushes the
devil kind of guy I really take offense
it's sort of the the comparisons to
totalitarianism somebody sent me an
email recently and compared you know
this administration what it was doing to
what had been done in sort of Communists
the count early years of the Communist
Soviet Union and there was some
comparison and I just wrote me i write
this people i consider it my personal
responsibility as a journalist to write
people back even when they're praising
me and being nice and i don't need the
fight you know to write people back and
say look i have to reject this premise
this is not good like there's nothing
about this country today that was true
in the early years of the Communist
Soviet Union Lee you know you say what
you want about george w bush he is not
Stalin so let's not you know be
ridiculous having said that I think his
legacy will be treated harshly I'm not
alone of course that's a majority of you
but my and my reason if for no other
reason if you took all the policies at
it so you just took a rock out of it
let's say let's say a rock is not the
defining thing of his defining issue we
think it is now or let's say it's not
foreign policy if for no other reason
then he entered office at a time of
incredible paralyzing division in the
country that he promised to mend it and
that he made it infinitely worse that is
his greatest disservice as a president
that alone makes him a failed president
if nothing else did in my mind because
he he retarded the dialogue in the
conversation in a country that
desperately needed to advance it and for
that I think history will judge him
harshly and whatever else you know
whatever else comes out of his
presidency will be judged beyond that
you